- Les trois meurtres commis
rappellent à bien des gens
e au sabre, survenue
il y a deux ans à Québec.
RÉGIS LABEAUME, ancien maire
- C'est un événement
hallucinant, terrifiant.
- Dans les deux cas,
les auteurs avaient de lourdatr.
Donc, la question se pose :
Comment prévenir de tels crimes?
Des CIUSSS de Montréal offrent
déjà des suivis ile.
Dr CÉDRIC ANDRES, chef, départ.
psychiatrie, CIUSSS Centre-Sud
la communauté, qui font
tes à domicile,
donc des suivis intensifs
dans le milieu par exemple,ble.
- Des suivis qui peuvents'étires
par mois, selon les besoins
du patient.nté mentale,
dépendances, itinérance, CIUSSS
- Nous suivons des patients,
ce qu'on appelle communément
des patients qui oiminels, maist
reconnus non responsables.
- Mais pour la criminologue
insuffisant.
MARIA MOminologue et
prés. de Mourani-criminologie
- Même s'il y a un suivi,
quand il va récidiver. Alors,
i une infirmière vient
le rencontrer à la maison
ou la semaine avant le délit,
il a l'air de prendre
ses médicaments.
- Or, à l'Institut
de psychiatrie légale
pour qu'un patient reprenne
sa vie en société, c'est toute
une équipe interdisciplinaire
qui l'accompagneréhabilitation.
Dr MATHIEU DUFOUR, chef du
département de psychiatrie
- On les envoie, par exemple,
au Tim Hpendant un certain temp.
- Et même si son évaluation est
fondée sur des critères
scientifiques, le Dr Dufour
du système.
- Je pense que si on avait
de ressources, surtout
pour les suivre en clinique
spécialisées en psychiatrie
légale, je pense que ça seraitit
bien pour prévenir des récidives
de violence.
demande, pour sa part,
une meilleure coor
des intervenants, tant dans
la sphère criminelleEt pendant s
font le deuil de leurs proches,
l'enquête, elle, les véritables
motivations du tireur à Laval
et à Montréal.
Ici, Gabrielle Proulx,